late night comic stephen colbert accused
of a double standard when it comes to
capital security after seven producers
who worked for his show got arrested for
unlawful entry to the capitol building
the colbert crew said to be filming a
comedy segment in an area that was
closed to visitors and had been told to
leave the building earlier in the day
the capital police say they are
continuing to investigate the breach
uh greg as someone that has a show you
sometimes go out and do skits is this
was this the right thing for them to be
doing in an area where they should not
have been
this is an insurrection
yeah uh yeah no you always kind of like
you know do stuff like this they were
likely let in i think they were led in
by somebody
your democratic staffer which reminds us
probably that's how the experience was
for 90 95 of the people on january 6
they kind of wandered in like it was
high school after dark you know i don't
know if you've ever done that but hey
let's go check out the principal's
office let's go raid the girls locker
room the media can't ever say that but
when you look at like a lot of the
footage all you see are the real jerks
and you don't see these people just kind
of wandering around going like what the
hell is going on yeah i mean i don't
know this story doesn't really inflame
me
judge look this is the same charge that
was levied against the vast majority of
those arrested on january 6.
a lot of those people have been in
solitary confinement for months a lot of
those people have lost money trying to
pay for a lawyer to to answer the
discovery that you need to in defending
yourself these people have to be treated
the same way you know and whether it's
you're you're in high school and you go
to the principal's office and all that
you know we're not dealing with kids
we're dealing with people who figured we
don't have the right to do this we were
told several times we don't have the
right to do this and yet they did it so
they should they should suffer the same
consequences i mean after all don't we
have equal justice in america i'm not
being cynical but that day the capital
was closed to everyone on that on the
day we're talking about this is closed
to them at that time but the capital was
open i don't disagree i think that
people should be treated the same
algorithms
jesse well we broke the story live on
jesse waters prime time at
and unlike greg i am very very worked up
about this the fact that the mug shots
haven't been released or the
surveillance footage has not been
released i don't know if there's a
cover-up going on with the capitol
police department but if they're going
to release mugs and surveillance from
the rioters on the six why can't we see
colbert's seven whatever they are i've
done a lot of hijinks and shenanigans in
the capitol with cameras on the factor
and you got to know where the line is
and i've gotten away with some stuff
maybe i shouldn't have but if you get
kicked out you don't come back in and
then
slam doors with your fists at 8 30 at
night i mean that is pretty bad you got
to show a little respect to the
institution as you know i'm an
institutionalist i think that's what's
been missing from what we were talking
about which is they were asked to leave
three times uh then this democratic
staffer let them in and then they were
wandering around without anybody there i
used to give capital tours that was my
job i love that job you can't just let
people wander around you have a
responsibility so that democratic
staffer should also be in trouble um and
also they were being jerks and
yelling and causing a problem you get
you don't do that i thought that they
wanted dignity and grace in the capital
let's see they're trying to drum up some
publicity because gutfield's hammering
them at late night that is true i think
you just hit on the essential truth of
this segment yes they're trying to pull
stunts to boost the ratings yes and it's
desperate it's very desperate and we see
right through them are they gonna get
fired
i hope so no they'll probably get a
raise yeah one more thing is up next hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now